-  Aaron Rodgers
You're the greatest
quarterback we've ever seen
You've been carrying
this team for a decade
-Guys, guys,
you've got to start the show.
-One more. One more.
-One more time!
-  Aaron Rodgers
You're the greatest
quarterback we've ever seen
-Welcome to "Simms & Lefkoe."
This is Simms. I am Lefkoe.
Want to say anything?
-Hey, what's up, everybody?
I'm Simms.
-That was awesome.
A packed show today. Simms,
Sean McVay remembering plays.
We got Martellus Bennett
in studio.
The guy is hilarious.
-Awesome. He's the man.
-And we have an incredible story
of DeAngelo Hall
with Paris Hilton
and that guy from 'Baywatch.'
-Oh, David Hasselhoff
is his name.
-Thank you.
-Don't worry. I'll help you out.
Keep going there.
Limp along. Keep going.
-This is why people think we're
scripted, 'cuz  you tell --
"This is why
we're gonna do this."
But we were -- We really do love
Aaron Rodgers
with all of our heart.
-Yes.
-Can you explain to people
how hard it is to do what he did
on Sunday with that leg?
-I mean, it's something
I look at and go,
"Lefkoe, there's only
a few quarterbacks in the
history of the sport that
I think could play with that."
That was phenomenal,
let alone to be able
to get the amount
of power and velocity
on the ball that's needed,
like the Geronimo Allison bomb.
-It was 52 yards in the air
with a bum leg.
-On one leg, yes.
-We just saw Rodgers
get hurt last year.
Is it worth the risk?
Why is he not thinking
about being injured?
How does he handle that?
-I think this is one
of the things that goes
untalked about in the sport.
You know why he can go,
"I'm playing, no matter what"?
'Cuz he just got
long-term security.
Why does nobody talk about that?
-'Cuz he just
got the contract.
-He got a huge contract,
so now he goes,
"Okay, the team's backing me,
and I'm gonna do everything
to prove them right
by giving me all this money,
and I know they gave me
all this money
to be the leader of the team.
And I'm gonna go out there
and show everybody,
even though I'm hurt,
I can make it happen."
-I'm so happy they paid
Aaron Rodgers.
-  Oh, Aaron Rodgers
-  You're the greatest
quarterback we've ever seen
-Simms, it is time for...
-Whoa!
-..."Big Take."
-The internet's funny, man.
Something happens
in a football game,
they jump all over it, like our
boy Sam Darnold threw the pick.
-Right. Everybody's experts.
-"He was the worst ever!"
-They're experts.
-So, everybody has a slant.
We're here to straighten it out.
And I saw a lot of attack
on Big Ben on Sunday.
And I get it.
Had a lot of picks.
Here are some
of the takes, Simms.
I want to straighten them out.
First one --
"As a Steelers fan,
I'm officially over
the Big Ben Roethlisberger era.
Shake my head."
This one -- "Big Ben
Roethlisberger, is that you?"
A floating dumpster
down the river.
-Ohh.
-And, then, we even had, like,
a more official article.
"Ben Roethlisberger's five
turnovers cost the Steelers
big-time in tie with Browns."
-Oh, okay.
-Um, I feel like you don't...
-Thank you, Captain Obvious.
-Where do you stand
on the "Big Ben is trash,
he's washed, it's over"?
-[ sarcastically ]
Oh, yeah, I know. He's trash.
I mean, he only was fifth in
touchdowns last year in the NFL.
He only threw for 469 yards
and five touchdowns
against the
best defense in football
in the divisional playoff game,
and then, when we get
to this game alone,
okay, he threw
three interceptions.
Only one was his fault.
One time, there was
a miscommunication
with Antonio Brown.
Another one went off
Jesse James' head.
Are we gonna blame
Ben Roethlisberger for fumbling
when the center
snapped the ball on the ground
and then no one blocked
Myles Garrett
as he got blindsided?
I didn't know Ben was
supposed to snap the ball,
block the left end,
and throw the football.
They should be paying him more.
-And missed the field goal
in overtime.
-Oh, and missed the --
And wait.
Wasn't it James Conner
who fumbled
and they returned the ball
back to the 1-yard line?
I'm sick of unqualified people
making qualifying statements.
I'm sick of it. Yeah.
-Wow.
-So, Big Ben...
-He's still really awesome.
He's one of the best
deep-ball throwers in football.
And let's not forget
it was a monsoon in Cleveland.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah. Oh.
I forgot about that.
And Cleveland's defense is gonna
be one of the best in football.
Okay, next subject. Let's go.
-I'm actually super-excited
that you're mad,
but we don't like to take
our anger out on the players.
It's really the coaches' fault
in Week 1.
-Yes.
-It's a little segment
that we like to call "Get 'Em!"
Where are we starting?
-Oh, we're starting with
the Falcons' red-zone offense.
"Oh, we're gonna get the ball
more to Julio Jones this year.
We're gonna be more creative
in the red zone."
Oh, here's their plan for Week 1
against the Eagles.
Straight line, straight line,
straight line.
What the hell were you doing
all offseason?
-Get 'em!
-Oh, hello, Cowboys offense.
I haven't seen you this year.
What the hell did you do
this offseason?
Did we come up with a game plan
or anything
schematically creative
to help out the pass game
or Dak Prescott?
-Probably not. Get 'em!
-Gosh.
Oh, and the Saints defense --
I don't know what you've been
doing in the offseason
for the last five years!
You can't win a Week 1 game,
and everybody was open
against "Fitzmagic."
I mean, it was the greatest show
I've ever seen,
and it was the Bucs
and Ryan Fitzpatrick.
-Get 'em!
-Oh, hello, Seattle.
"We're gonna protect
Russell Wilson
and help him out more this year.
It's going --
We're going to Denver,
and, oh, um, uh,
oh, yeah, they have Von Miller.
We'll just leave him one-on-one
against our crappy
right tackles all game
and let Russell figure it out
and just run away."
-Got 'em!
Man, did that feel good?
-Man, I feel a lot better. Whew!
-This is like therapy for you.
-I had to get that off my chest.
-If there's one coach, though,
that definitely is prepared,
it's Sean McVay.
They won their first game by 20,
and their team didn't
even play all preseason.
He's so prepared,
he never forgets a thing.
We saw you on television,
and you remembered
a ton of plays, okay?
-What do you think
of Sean's brain?
-What? It's out of this world.
It's better than mine.
I can tell you that.
-Week 12, Saints at Rams.
4:29 in the second quarter.
2nd and 7 on the Saints' 7.
What happens?
-Oh, Josh Reynolds touchdown
off scheduled play
versus a 3-man rush.
-You're absolutely right.
-Are you kidding me?
-You're unbelievable.
-He's like a computer.
-Now we are going to go to --
This is Sean McVay's
time in Washington.
-Oh, no.
-Ooh, I like it.
-So we're bringing it
back to 2015.
Week 7. Bucs at Skins.
-Yep.
-2nd and 7
on the Tampa Bay 24.
58 seconds left
in the fourth quarter.
-Jamison Crowder wheel route
down the right sideline.
Set up the first down,
and then how did that drive end?
-Jordan Reed touchdown
in a 4x1 individual iso slant.
-And what meme was that game?
-You liked that!
-He's good.
He's real good.
Check out the brain on Sean.
-You're amazing.
-All right.
2005 NFC Wild Card Game.
Washington and Tampa Bay.
-Ah.
-9:47 left in the third.
-Sean Taylor.
-3rd and 2 on
the Washington 2-yard line.
-Oh, well, this is my play.
They're cheating
to make it equal.
They're cheating.
-What's the play?
-I bootlegged out on the left
and dove in for a touchdown.
Yeah, it's one of my only...
-Do you remember?
-My only rushing touchdown.
-Of course.
-But do you remember?
-You know what?
Chris was playing with the Bucs.
That was my first year
in coaching.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
We spent a little bit of time.
He won't even remember --
We had some breakfasts
together, you know,
talked a little ball,
but that was...
What did he eat at breakfast?
No, I actually take it back.
When I worked
-this was before I coached
for the Bucs...
-yes
It was when I was
working training camp,
the year after they
had won the Super Bowl,
I was working as, like, a --
You know, being a water boy,
whatever.
-Right, right.
-Just kind of running around.
-That's awesome. That's awesome.
-Yeah, that's right.
-Everybody remembers
Todd Gurley's screen
for a touchdown
against the Cowboys.
What happened the play
before the big touchdown?
-Screen to Malcolm Brown.
-And that is why
he's Sean McVay.
There's only, like,
a few people, I think,
in the world
that can keep up with us
and I think are funny,
and I think Martellus Bennett's
one of those guys.
-Why, thank you.
I think that's a compliment.
-Yeah.
-It was a weird compliment.
-Your brother, too.
He can be there with us, too.
-Yeah. Oh.
-That would've been good.
Yeah, you're two
of our favorites.
-You know, the grape doesn't
fall far from the vine.
-That's what they say. Yes.
-Yeah.
-I like, since
it's not a quarterback,
I get to sit next to him, too.
-Yeah. Right.
-And, also, I think this
is the Eagles fans now.
-Well, I don't know.
-He's officially
an Eagles fan.
-I am an Eagles fan.
-I hear you.
-Yeah.
-Jump on the bandwagon.
-I'm not -- No.
I'm a Michael Bennett fan.
-Yes. And he plays
for the Eagles.
-He plays for the Eagles, so
I'm rooting for him to do well,
so I'm rooting
for them to do well.
-Yes, okay.
-I still think "Fly, Eagles Fly"
is the worst song
ever written by anyone,
next to the national anthem.
-Right.
-Really?
-Next to the national anthem.
Okay.
-Coming out...
-Hardcore!
-Do you like the "E-A-G-L-E-S"
at the end, though?
Come on.
-No, I don't like any of it.
I mean, if I played for them,
I would love it.
-Perfect. But you're a fan now.
-It's like saying
if I liked country music,
I would love country music,
but I don't like country music.
-What was it like Sunday
being a fan?
That's, like,
your first time out...
-I didn't watch
much football Sunday.
-No?
-What did I do on Sunday?
Sunday, I --
Oh, I was at Harvard.
-Excuse me.
-[ laughs ]
-Our first Sunday
was not the same.
That's why he's
a lot cooler than me.
-What do you mean?
-I mean, my first Sunday
without football, I was a wreck.
I was crying.
-Really?
-I was, like,
the exact opposite.
I was watching every game
and like,
"I can't believe this guy's
playing and I'm not."
-I was wondering this, though.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Is it different if you retire
when you want to retire
and when the league
pushes you out?
-I think so,
and they pushed me out.
-See, I retired when I wanted --
I was done.
-Right. So, again, you're cool.
-So I'm happy with what I did,
you know?
A lot of guys --
I think they're --
I wouldn't say bitter,
necessarily.
-Right.
-But they're bitter...
about someone else being in.
They feel like they still could
do it, they can still go play.
And then you go try out for
the...
-the Canada teams when you're 42.
-No. Never.
Not happening.
-No.
-NFL or nothing.
-You were talking earlier
about retiring when you want
and being forced out.
I feel like I'm looking at Dez,
and I'm seeing the tweets,
and I can see the frustration.
And you've been
in that organization.
What the hell is happening
with Dez right now?
-These teams can build
perceptions about players
Right, and if you take a meeting
and you don't kill
that perception in that meeting,
they start to believe
what everyone else has said.
-It becomes reality.
-Yeah. It becomes your reality.
-Yeah.
-So, I think, with Dez,
his thing --
I think that, you know,
trying to control the situation,
but, at the same time,
the best thing you can do
to control the situation
is just chill.
-Mm.
-Physically, he can still play.
There's like --
People will sign Eric Decker.
-Yes.
-Like, you know?
There's receivers
getting signed all the time.
-No, the talent's there.
-Same thing with, like,
an Eric Reid.
Like, there's safeties
getting signed...
that can't play better
than Eric Reid.
It's just like -- But you're
gonna pass up on this guy?
-End game, though --
how do you see Dez ending --
Like, end game here? Because
I don't want him to go too long
without playing here, too,
'cause, like, I like Dez, too.
I don't think he's
a superstar anymore,
but I want to see him
on the field,
and he deserves
to be on the field.
-I look at teams
that I think would be good.
I think one team
that comes to mind for me
that would've been great for him
would've been the Chargers.
-Mm.
-I think the personality
of the quarterback is gonna make
Dez a better player, right?
So, playing with a Tom Brady
or playing with a...
-A Philip Rivers, yeah.
-...a Philip Rivers,
who has that fire
and can match Dez's fire
and he believes in that fire,
it's gonna be a better
situation for him,
because they're gonna have that
mutual respect for one another,
as far as competitors.
All these coaches talk about
they want guys
who love football.
Like, "Let's get some
football guys in here."
But when you have a guy who
loves football so much that --
They label him as a guy
that's like a diva,
but he just wants to win,
he wants to play,
and he loves playing football.
-Right.
-So, if you can get those
three things out of most guys,
'cause most guys
don't really love it
the way they say they love it.
They just say that shit
until they get the check,
'cause most of these people
aren't who they really say
they are --
it's just a facade.
-Yeah, some fugazis.
-Yeah, they just play
the game very well.
I wasn't interested
in playing that game.
I was into playing
the game of football.
-Martellus,
we appreciate you, man.
Again, check out Martellus'
show, 'Mostly Football'.
Yahoo?
-And Complex.
And my new podcast called
'Revenge of the Jocks'.
-Almost as many jobs as you.
-Oh, 'Revenge of the Jocks.
I want to get
a little something here.
-Oh, man.
-I thought I was the only one
that was gonna get one.
-He has a little more flavor
than you.
You're like --
You know, like --
-You don't have as much cacao
as he has.
-Yeah!
He knows white chocolate
when he sees it!
-I wasn't ready for that.
[ laughter ]
-Hey, what's going on, guys?
I'm Reggie Bush.
And you're watching
"Simms & Lefkoe."
-So, if you know
"Simms & Lefkoe," you know
that, when he's evaluating
players, you really care
about two body parts --
the legs and the ass.
-And the ass, yes.
-A lot of people
are weirded out,
but you believe that
if you got those two things,
you're going to be good.
-You got a chance.
Lawrence Taylor.
Reggie White. Barry Sanders.
You look at their lower halves,
it's pretty impressive,
and then you can go, "Man.
Hall of Fame type of players."
-Don't be blinded by the bicep
is what you're saying.
-That means nothing. Right.
-So, take me through five guys
at different positions
that you think have a nice set.
-Okay, well, let's start
at the running-back position,
because this guy here,
a rookie
Saquon Barkley.
I mean, this is the most
unbelievable lower half
I've ever seen
in a running back, maybe.
I mean,
his nickname is "Saquad,"
and he's been there
for a few months.
And, Lefkoe, have you ever seen
anybody bounce outside
on Jacksonville Jaguars
and run for a 68-yard touchdown?
That doesn't happen.
That's because he has
an unbelievable legs and ass.
-Let's go to defense. Bosa.
-Oh.
Joey Bosa is incredible
lower half.
You want to know why he's one
of the best speed pass rushers
in football, power pass rushers?
He can do it all.
He's awesome in run blocking.
So, yes, another guy...
-It all stems from the stems.
-It all stems from down there.
-Let's go to a rookie.
-Rookie.
-Daron Payne.
-So impressive.
The first time --
-Not a lot of people
know this guy.
-Daron Payne is going to be
one of the best interior
defensive linemen in this sport,
and you can see right there.
-Look at that.
-I mean, it looks like
he's got a turkey in there.
I don't know what that is,
but all I know is,
I turned on the
first preseason game
when he was playing the Jets
and things like that.
I said, "Who is this guy
with this legs and butt,
and who is creating havoc
all over the field?"
-Yeah.
-Oh, it's 95, Daron Payne.
Watch out for him.
-Look out for him this season.
A guy at a similar position
that's been doing it
for a while --
this is not just legs and ass --
this is legs and high ass.
-Oh, this is a --
It's a little different.
-Stephon Tuitt.
-It's nuanced here, yes.
His high ass is what's
very impressive to me.
Look how comfortable he is
in that position
and he has a freaky lower half.
-And, then, the last guy --
I didn't expect a quarterback
to be on this list.
-It's really rare.
-But if you always wonder,
"Why is Russell Wilson
breaking tackles?"
-Right.
-Probably 'cause of his legs.
-And running around everywhere.
We saw him in training camp
a few years ago.
We know he probably has some
inner-thigh chaffage there,
but it's unbelievable
to see a quarterback
with that type of lower half.
It's really rare
for that position,
but he does make the list.
He can make some unbelievable
plays with his legs.
-Yes.
-It's about as good as I've
ever seen at the
quarterback position.
-So, if you want to steal Simms'
idea, look at legs and ass.
One guy that's stolen
a lot from you...
-Oh, my gosh.
-...DeAngelo Hall.
-Oh, he -- I mean, every time
he was on the field,
I felt like I threw
an interception to him.
I threw a lot of
interceptions, though.
-Well, look, he's amazing,
and he's got an amazing story
about a little trip to Vegas.
Rookie hazing
is always legendary.
-Yes.
-I can't imagine what it's like
when you're the eighth pick
in the draft.
-They feel like
you got money to burn, man.
So, they tell I have to take
them to Vegas -- rookie hazing.
I'm like, "All right, cool."
I had never been to Vegas.
And one night, we pick a club.
You know, it's DB night.
I'm the rookie.
I got to pay for everything.
-Yeah.
-And I was kind of
looking at the bottles
that we were anticipating
on buying,
and I'm looking like, "Whew.
Man, I didn't know that bottle
cost that much," you know?
I was kind of doing that,
but as the night wore on, man,
it was --
it was bigger than that.
On one side of our table
is Paris Hilton
and her crew of lovely ladies.
-Right.
-On the other side
is David Hasselhoff
and his crew
of lovely ladies, as well.
He had on a black
kind of shiny shirt,
unbuttoned to probably
his belly button --
you know, vintage
David Hasselhoff gear
that he probably
would still wear.
-Right. Right.
-I had never met
another celebrity
besides other athletes.
I was, without a doubt, shocked.
And like I said, man,
Hasselhoff had a --
His crew might have been better
than Paris' crew.
Our table --
looking like we probably ain't
even supposed to be in there.
We don't even have no girls
over there with us,
so we're all just kind of
partying at their tables.
Initially, they had joked
about me having to pay
for all the tabs,
the three -- those tables,
'cuz we were
at all the tables.
They're like,
"Man, we can't let them go.
We drunk all their liquor."
I'm like, "Well, somebody
got to pay for that.
I got our table."
Our bill ended up being
around 15 grand or so.
And before I could
even put my card down,
Paris had took my bill...
-Oh, my gosh. What?
-...and paid my tab.
-Damn!
Well, she should've.
She's a Hilton.
-Hey, she had the most money
in the room, without a doubt.
But I always tell people that
story, and they think I'm lying.
But I promise you, man.
it's the damnedest thing.
I wish I could meet her
and say, "Thank you."
-So you're a big
Paris Hilton fan.
-I'm a Paris Hilton fan, man,
'cause she took over my check.
-So you got an extra $15,000.
-I kind of got off unscathed.
-It is time for
"Somebody & Lefkoe."
Bleacher Report gives me money
to bet on
'Thursday Night Football',
but I let random New Yorkers
pick the team.
They win, and I got to pay them,
and that's why we got to see
my good friend Allie.
We are back in the newsstand,
and that means
that the Eagles
have covered the spread,
and my main man Allie
has won himself some money.
-Yeah!
-Congratulations.
Here is $113...
-Yes.
-...and sixty --
I dropped a dime.
-Don't worry about it.
-...65 cents.
I've done the math.
That is 90 packs of Starbursts.
-[ laughs ] I like it.
-I don't think you're gonna
use your money there.
-No.
-You gonna take the lady out
for a nice dinner?
-No, no, no,
I'm gonna let it build up
over the next couple of weeks.
-What? Next couple of weeks?
I like what he's saying.
All right.
This week, it is the Ravens,
who just steamrolled the Bills,
at the Bengals,
who hung on to beat the Colts.
And the Ravens are favored
by 1 in Cincinnati.
Take me through your mind-set.
-I don't know.
I like --
The last couple of matchups,
the Bengals have beat them,
what, 5 out of 6?
-5 of the last 6 times
in Cincinnati.
-In Cincinnati.
-He knows his stuff.
-A home game. Prime time.
-Yeah.
-I like the Bengals.
-Really?
-Going with the Bengals.
-Wow!
Even after the Ravens
looked amazing in Week 1.
-They looked good, but the Bills
aren't the Bengals.
I like the Bengals.
-I love it.
He's siding with
Marvin Lewis and the Bengals.
Is that the official bet?
-Yes, sir.
-$250 on the Bengals.
If he's right,
I'll be back here next week.
-Sounds great.
See you next week. [ laughs ]
-We'll figure that out by then.
Simms, Lefkoe, back to you.
So, my man Allie
is going Bengals.
I do like a good defense at home
on Thursday night,
but does he get
the Simms stamp of approval?
-The Bengals have had
the Ravens' number
the last few years,
but I'm going with the Ravens.
I think this is a different
Ravens football team this year.
-Really.
-A true Super Bowl contender.
-And they're finally healthy.
-Yes, they are.
-If they can avoid penalties.
-Right.
-If there's a lot of penalties
in your game,
we're keeping the same hashtag,
and you're frustrated
with the refs,
hit them with the hashtag
#KeepItInYourPants.
-We're talking about
flags and the referees.
-Thank you.
-Yeah.
-Clarification Simms.
-Yep.
-Sam Darnold --
I'm so happy for our young man.
-Sammy the Savior!
-We welcomed him to New York.
Is he finally the answer
to the Jets' quarterback woes?
-I do think so.
And throw a pick-six
on your first play ever...
and then just act like
it didn't even happen
and come back
and ball after that?
That's why they
took him number 3.
Way to go, Sammy!
-Sammy! Sam is a pro.
We're gonna
eventually become pros.
For Simms...
-Peace out, homies.
-...I'm Lefkoe.
We'll holla, holla, holla
at you next week.
-Yeah.
-So, stand right here.
-We'll make it quick, Sean.
-You stand here.
Face the camera
a little bit more.
-Yeah.
-Okay.
Hello and welcome.
I am split right now --
No, this one, Sean.
He doesn't know
where the cameras are,
but they're football brainiacs.